[Music]
if you're watching this thing you know
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
youtube plays immediately shrink bagels
i've made a shocking discovery
need you to get me in touch with nasa
immediately well nasa and i aren't
really on speaking terms these days well
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic not spacey
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
nasa
you're the unidentified source oh yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing
i'm asking you for your help
say yes brian
i need you to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is
suit up
horizon you have got a big gravity wave
coming your way you have to launch now
did he say gravity wave
we're underwater guys
uh that's crazy
what's the plan save the mill and save
earth
wait for it
let's go you son
[Music]
everybody hang on i'm gonna get you
[Music]
home it's on airplane mode
[Music]
it's too dangerous why we tampered with
the stability of space-time
the multi-burst
is a concept about which we know
frighteningly little
your destination
it was the only way
but i never
meant for any of this
happened
[Music]
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
[Music]
i'm sorry steven
i hope you understand
the greatest threat
to our universe
[Music]
is you
things just got out of hand
[Music]
hey kid a little young for a bartender
aren't you a little old for prom aren't
you
[Music]
everything in here why the map it's the
biggest treasure that's never been found
5 billion easy but it's just a story i
beg to differ
[Music]
500 years ago
my family found the world's biggest
fortune
then was betrayed
people have been searching for it all in
vain
both you turn your keys clockwise at the
same time
thanks a lot you almost got me killed
clockwise sully well it was 50 50 so i
made a guess clearly
but the voyage was not just about gold
or something much more valuable this
cross has a very tragic history so much
blood
[Music]
i'm pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me
don't get caught
you were just gonna leave me back there
somebody had to get the cross
[Music]
[Applause]
your brother believed that there was a
final piece
well you know my brother said
you have no idea who you partnered with
else aren't you telling me
the victor
spoils
how are they gonna get them out of here
uh
[Music]
hey put them down boys
what is that thing on your face
puberty's right around the corner kids
you can grow your own
in movie theaters
bruce wayne
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
your family has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything
the riddler
is asking for you the killer left this
for the batman why is he writing to you
you came
i've been trying to reach you
look there's latest it's all about the
wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats everything about
strikes
the bat in the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruised
away
all these years
lied
we all have our scars bruce he's still a
wine
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know he's up with
delaney
where are you under there
what are you hiding selena you'll throw
your life away
don't worry honey i get nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied it's your violence
you may find
justice
the answer's justice
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
newlyweds mr and mrs simon doyle
you must meet archul puero my
congratulations madam mercy
but he's only the greatest detective
alive
i suspect you invited me for reasons
other than the fun
you had something so high we have the
karnak all to ourselves a chef and
enough champagne to fill the nile
when you have money no one is ever
really your friend
it's too late to change events it's time
to face the consequences
someone is dead
[Music]
the crime
is murder
ever again
the murderer
is one of you
were you aware of any grudges madam is
used to getting what she wants
never again
i don't feel safe
i don't feel safe with any of them
there are so many conflicting hates and
jealousies
oh i like this did you see or hear
anything
i did not trust her i still don't what
did you do last night you accused me of
murder
he accuses everyone of murder it is a
problem i admit
that murder was methodically planned
[Music]
you are mad
can i not trust you what do you want me
to say
[Music]
someone else is dead
you lie in my face lock the doors
the murderer is here and we'll stay here
[Music]
by the pricking of my thumbs
something wicked this way comes
my husband
king that shelby
[Music]
if we should fail
we fail
[Music]
does thou not hear noise
he thought i heard a voice cry sleep no
more
[Music]
the devil
i have no words my voice is in my sword
the world waited for what felt like
forever
then
[Applause]
we waited longer
but this february
we promise is gonna be the gnarliest
[ __ ] ever
the wait is over
hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough
when you get knocked down
if they trust us to go to the bathroom
they're less intelligent than i thought
i've been in the drawer but i know
enough
to know
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough you're still blowing people up as
if life's not hard enough this guy's one
badass dude
oh man i'm on jackass it's a texas rat
snake venomous
francis hits harder than any heavyweight
in the mma i told aaron it was a light
weight
that's not
what are you talking about
[Music]
we're in this together
what's the worst that could happen
you said it wasn't gonna feel like
anything
i just need you to like sit with my
grandpa just make sure he doesn't smoke
[Music]
will you make him an actual coffee
stephanie got to be over dude i think
we're all the way finished with fruit
stick or fork in it
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh no crashing eddie went back to the
lost world and i thought i made bad
choices
hello boys butt wild at your service our
hero
what brings you two to my world we want
to live a life of adventure like you is
the bad time for a tropical vacation
everyone we face a grave threat can you
repeat that
i had a marshmallow in my ear
crashing eddie you've been gone a while
shouldn't we just be looking for bones
at this point thanks sid
this is our chance to prove ourselves
boys what you lack in intelligence
destiny
oh destiny hurts
you make up for him bumbling ineptitude
hang on
if we don't find them i'm gonna kill
them
[Applause]
[Music]
now
behold
he's here
he's here
father is here the kingman lady the king
your fake is sick and you cannot escape
it
now i've missed you my son
one day this kingdom will be yours
thank you father my king
[Music]
[Music]
why would they stow away to such a
hellish
place to find what was stolen from me
and what is that
the kingdom
you must choose between kindness for
your gift
for hate for your
your
enemies
breaks man's bones
[Applause]
i have the cunning to break their minds
and night by night we will carry out my
pledge of vengeance
i will avenge your father
[Music]
larson i need you to come over to my
house and hook up with me every day
after school
what yeah you me sex stuff
how about a little backstory while i was
setting the academic bar for our
generation my classmates were more
concerned with other things
i'm dtf
oh
[ __ ] we both know you don't do things
you're not great at god i can't be bad
at this this is not the time to be a
perfectionist i'm gonna blow you blow
whatever you're comfortable with
to master sexual excellence i'm going to
create an app that would collect data
and prescribe steps for a successful
sexual experience i should be collecting
data from my fellow students
there are certain partnered pleasure
approaches the rock and roll the surfs
up the double action revolver the spock
the reverse spot damn if you want to be
a dick-sucking artist a penis picoxo a
bonnet afrida [ __ ] glow
it's all about the tip
have you selected a practice partner yet
i can't sexualize you i respect you too
much for your brain for your
independence my god
i can't believe you just did that it's
fair play
technically it's for play don't be mad
here we go godspeed
i think we can call today's experiment a
success
i have a hypothesis love leads to sex
and sex leads to love our dynamic needs
to remain strictly professional for the
sake of the experiment so if we're not
doing your experiment we can't hang
you kids are overly worried about
getting good at the sex stuff it's a
relationship that takes practice
[Music]
stay safe
larson are we ready oh yeah
it's happening
you just launched a harpoon without
tying the rope off i'll tie it off i i
have several ropes ribbed ropes
pre-lubed ropes
reel it in skipper
you got to try things to know what you
want there's a diversity of options
you've got your lefties your righties
your straight shooters your curvatures
i'll just be at hometown buffet sampling
the local beef don't be mad at the
confidence
i thought we had a love that was out of
a novel and no matter how hard it was
we'd survive to tell the story crazy
[Music]
we can we can survive it i don't want to
survive
i want to live
we're just a bomb waiting to explode
[Music]
holding me tight
i'm sorry i couldn't fix you
[Music]
where's the front door
just tell me yeah right there straight
ahead
so i'll make it quick because i'm late
for my flight the security system's just
down the hall the guest room's all ready
for you ciao
have a safe play
see for me connect to a sighted helper
on demand for visual assistance in a
live video call
high ceilings fireplace and floor to
ceiling windows with a great view
thank you
system disarmed
hey quiet
we've got a problem i think someone's
here
see for me
hey how can i help you there's people in
the house are you sure yeah i think
they're looking for me
[Music]
[Music]
we need to offer right now she's seen
our faces no i have it
what's going on here
where's the girl
please listen to me
they're gonna kill you
what should i do
oh what a mistake baby
kelly
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
be
i want to break up with you what
[Music]
hello
is everything okay
you have mascara all over your whole
face you actually have
like a piece of toilet paper
other side
just got dumped i want to break up with
you what
oh me too
i'm breaking up with you
oh
my god
what about this whatever we're feeling
like we just can't take it anymore
let's kill each other
for each other's sadness sisters well
sadness sister sounds like you're dying
keaton and i'm meryl streep and we're in
a broadway play but oh i get yeah that's
a great cast
you should cast please
oh my god and look at her with my
boyfriend this is bad
what the [ __ ]
he was the love of my life and is the
love of mine but i'm not so sure that
they're gonna realize it not with these
shiny new people around what are we
supposed to do
we have to break them up that's crazy we
can't do that
how would we do that
[Music]
i will seduce anne's boyfriend am i
doing this right it's so wet you just
take your two fingers let it drip out oh
thank you yeah i don't think we've met
hi
oh you will friendship seduce noah
what about your ex really funny was she
funny
pop that shirt off i'd rather not i'll
tell you what i'll take mine off too
that's not gonna help me at all
can i tell you a little secret about
being an adult
all just pretending that we know what
we're doing and we're hoping that we
don't screw it up
your stamina has really improved it's
the drugs i find you both incredibly
attractive oh yeah
wow look at you good work yeah man i'm a
psycho
[Music]
you are somebody that a person could
fall very deeply in love with but it's
more like slowly
over five or six months okay or like a
year
two years top do you realize the numbers
going up
[Applause]
[Music]
increases
[Music]
sir remember the moving spike we spotted
in the infection rate
oops
sorry about that
what have you got kid well i
cross-correlated the data with worldwide
ir codes and it changes things
quite significantly it's impossible for
a strain to spread that fast crossing
borders at the speed of light
crisscrossing the globe in 24 hours
but when did you get those preposterous
figures uh
christmas eve
looks like you've got your clearance to
engage
the world has moved on
magic dust pieces of coal it's time for
something a little more reliable
do you have any idea what you've done
you've led them right to it
i didn't think any of this was great
it's real and now they won't stop until
it's all gone
[Music]
queer
visual position
[Music]
you